[Musik]
mit den check-in
doch das bild links und rechts
[Musik]
ok
mein name ist jonas ems achse zwanziger
sagte rapid die berufsbildung der ihk
meine männlichen recht gut aufarbeiten
[Musik]
gwd feg and risk i/o im kanton fribourg
radiomacher prüf und x2 prozent sieht
mir geboten
ich vermisse sachen haarscharf wenn man
das wahrscheinlich mit april wird
verglichen so gut gesetzt war sauber die
person nicht aus
[Musik]
im fernseher die santix vorgeschlagen
womit heuer vor allem dank zwei in
sachen reisen ist eigentlich technik
unter anderem die persönliche begegnung
ludwigshafen und da sein unbedingter wie
wichtig dass es sich dass mein anruf
dass möglich zeigt dass man miteinander
und dabei gar keine eigenes großes
verlagen statt
[Musik]
der motivator wissen reise häufig damit
konfrontiert ich soll mir überhaupt aus
planen die selbe hinter die karibik
staat alabama über north glüht turner
lehrer keine und das machte mir
unbedingt wieder antwort seeger das ist
auch spaß macht außer in der türkei sei
[Musik]
größer
ratlos wirkte das ja ja
fragen blog
[Musik]
dank der andere sind und dank der bgh
nunmehr fast im reise aussehen
[Musik]
nachts
da
räder hier
[Musik]
hier ist ihr zimmer und das ist ihre
karte
das ist der schlitz für die karte die
welle schlitz hier
[Musik]
das ist für den strom da von links
stecken sie die karte rein
warten sie kurz und dann öffnet sich die
tür ist das ja natürlich
geradeaus geht es zum badezimmer und zur
toilette
ach ja die gläser früchte
hier ist der kaffee wenn sie hilfe
brauchen
sagen sie einfach den hit me baby oder
jonas zweite geschoss er verfolge aber
halt nachrichten 40 und mitte november
an bis griechenland ausgesät wer
verletzt für griechenland tritt ist dass
ich sie also die flüchtlingskrise und
euro-krise hält auch griechenland und
hat eine große rolle gespielt und max
mutzke oder historisch muss man fast
davon
wir haben jetzt mehrere datensätze
kulinarischer grenzt aber auch so dass
künstlicher das hier so bedeutender ort
ist für viele surfer und denkt
demokratie und das fach außer die
historische platz
das getröte gelenkt
ich war
der linksabbieger die stadt
der ist auch leo fossilis nach westen
angekommen
das ist das beste was station war ja
ganz klar festgestellt
man geht raus wo man steht
mit black book muss ich
ja
was er machen
sorry
die coverstory
sie sprach ich das
cannabis frage ja gehts hier oder hier
in diese richtung
also dass dies die letzte freie hier
was wir hier
ja ja
str
[Musik]
bislang laufen wollte dass er
fortschritte des himmlischen der vorstoß
beim ausgang hätte ich mir schon zweiter
kategorie h künftig heißt sie schon mal
ausführlich vorbereiter dass man die
80er abgelenkt
mit dem anti verschiedene gehabt
navigations-apps was er gemacht hätte
wäre so google maps so stadtrat und die
idee drei siege akw oder dort und das
thema jetzt nicht super genau gewusst
wie es noch deutlich weniger mit einer
griechische name und mit der schrift
worden mit wirklich gut vor klasse wird
bevor sie sprachen es gab natürlich
wieso vorbereitung risikolos soll die
operation wahrscheinlich aber die
ästhetik des zwangsrabattes ja war hier
immer dazwischen
die hattstedter davon hinterher ja so
muss manchmal beispiel traktiert
und es folgt auf einer reise
recherchieren wie die zwischen der
richtige also internet wikipedia podcast
apathisch und ging gut verschlossen und
das 40 fans sandige kam ja nur große
kritik wäre mir hilft die kapelle
wütender ort ist wo ich so über die
ganze stadt
trotzdem dass mir das nicht gesehen ist
sehr spannend wird für touristen hätten
sie verlegt wurden und sich genießer und
mir her von der aussicht auf bis mit
chören start hochwichtig ob ich bin in
der stadt homs waren einfach stone und
ärzte
machen
nach oben
das muster könnte schon für ihre kann
sich nicht auf die reise geschickt mit
eigentlich gingen foto hey mein erstes
großes thema weiß und verstand so dass
das verdienen indem er einfach ist los
reyes problemsituation aber sie wohne ja
was bringt das überhaupt so dass jedes
je in frage stellt wo am avd ist wie
vielleicht nicht so mit sachen verstaut
ist wunderbar wie er stars und
schlussendlich sind gründer und da geht
es darum dass mit nur besser gesagt ich
mach das modell sowie naturgarten oder
bleibt oder so sondern es geht mehr um
rapists alaba war bis damit zu entdecken
und das macht spaß mit der promoter
score gut versteht
[Musik]
ja
abiturienten eingeschränkt
was als hobby
heimlich hat bis frage haben sie
interessiert hauptsache nette menschen
hier also wissen sogar denkt der krise
aber natürlich gehört das wort
finanzkrise liegt dass sie gegen ich
denke wir haben uns zwar ein bisschen
daran gewöhnt aber die situation ist
nicht viel besser als früher
aber wir haben gelernt dennoch eine gute
zeit zu verbringen
mit unseren freunden und der familie
[Musik]
halb sein könnte
aber wir sind nicht reich es geht uns
nicht viel besser es gibt viele leute
vor allem junge die keinen job finden
sie müssen auswandern
ich habe viele freunde die jetzt in
london leben und dort arbeiten oder in
spanien in schottland
unter der seite vor dem ja ich bin hier
geboren und ihr mann muss der schweiz
der neue verband der hauptstadt vor der
schweiz
[Musik]
mach dir verliehen die ferien für noch
locker und habt ihr spaß
[Musik]
der verteidiger spielte
der ganze globus können die hier
getroffen
links
[Musik]
wien apa
und das ist content bank
bisher wurde das ist klar
naja ein bisschen erwartet
aber besser aussieht als ich
hauptstadt
ja
zuvor jedoch viele linien kapuzen über
genau denn wissen grenzgebiet
unterstützt von der mut
ja ja jetzt hartz iv
bei
ja
ich das gas station vom 12
musik
warum
man hat dort ab nach ixia
wohin wollt ihr zum textilmuseum
das taxi das ist nicht der rechte fuß
ist aber exakt 250 habe damit hatte sie
zwar kein bus und muss sich nicht mit
100 meter gefahren und wie sie sich mit
genau hat für dazu der richtige station
ja ich jetzt hier
ok danke danke
der cube
b
die 2 aber ich schätze es extrem also
ich jetzt extrem die unkomplizierte art
die flexibilität des nehmens dass das
sehr widerwillig nicht bestanden ja wir
hatten wir aber auch die momente wo
mittel aber für kraft gab es mit einer
situation aus einer wohnung kompliziert
muss gespürt auf rang drei
backhaus zum sofa locken vor der tat
schon passieren
[Applaus]
thomas kurtz wird hier etwa die linke
sieht das für mehr forschung zum konzept
das man das museum für blinde und
sehbehinderte besucher erlaubt das auf
die schweiz oder die anderen ort der
häufig sie diese spezielle
dienstleistungen für blogger
sehbehinderte sie vielleicht gar nicht
überall barriere für das relativ kleine
sachen
lea metrisch
museum grundsätzlich soll das mini cars
fragen digital also lied von usecon
taktik hat so der plüschtiere effekt dem
sinnvoll oder den effekt dass man es
einfach hause alleine oder seidigen
immer gern aber ich glaube eine andere
kultur und clip papier ist auch wo sie
vielleicht eine düse sprachrohr nicht
englisch wird und sie probieren achtung
komplizierte schlussendliche hof führt
darum wird es ist super ich werde sie
zur museum führen
das ist fragte die vize-präsidentin also
ich würde sie zum museum
messi ist blind sie camp linzer welt
da sind wir also lassen sie mich ein
paar dinge über das museum sagen das
taktile museum hier wurde 1984 gegründet
es ist eines von vier oder fünf museen
dieser art weltweit
das spezielle hier ist dass wir alles
berühren können
sie sind sehr charakteristisch für die
klassische zivilisation sehen sie sie
haben nur die nase sie haben keine augen
keine ohren keine not keine haare nichts
vielleicht waren sie mit leuchtenden
farben angemalt
sie gehört dem louvre museum und sie
wurde auf milos gefunden einer
griechischen insel
diesen sektor oberkörper ist nackt unten
trägt hartley sehen sie und hier ist sie
nach frankfurt aber nicht mehr ganz
objekte drückt beträgt hier nicht so
kommt spürt unbedingt hier ist sondern
wie oft gespür entdecke
der umgang ist sehr sympathisch sie mit
habe ich noch schont so dass mit so
einfach so sprechen
das brauchte schon sucht noch vertrauen
finden weiß nicht ob das mit dem kommt
so oder so ähnlich wie wie 89 mal zieht
das man dir die stadt wurde gesperrt und
glaubte ja die angel usa und ich habe
für diese normal und das ist nichts was
die selbstverständlichkeit das hat mir
eigentlich schon die die dampfer schon
vor 2000 jahren wichtig sie nur ein foto
dpa nackt die anderen frauen waren nicht
nackt
aphrodite war die einzige göttin die
nackt dargestellt wurde
wenn wir eine nackte statur haben wissen
wir dass es aphrodite ist die person
vorsorge stark durch stellt den look zum
ausgang zu sein und nach einer der
langsamsten liedteile der vielleicht wie
stolz gemacht und beim hopfen visitator
und böse ist ja wir heuer mit der nummer
ist detail erfassen also fast immer dass
details nach startet die tränen als
ganzes vor deiner stadt
das heißt
musik
[Musik]
vorne
[Applaus]
danke das war kein griechischer liegt
aber ich bin griechen also ist es
vielleicht doch ein griechisches lied
danke ich werde meine hand und was ist
das für ein instrument wollen sie
versuchen zu stehen
das mit dauern
ja ich gebe es ihnen in die hand hier
sehen sie und sie hier in you
und hier ist das instrument nutzen
es ist das eisen
[Musik]
ich glaub mir läuft doch es war spieler
das den besten
[Musik]
sie sind mitten in der natur
[Gelächter]
es heißt schon hinaus
wir hören im zug kein problem machen sie
hier
auf der akropolis kam des service
bekannt
klage speziell so ganz geschichtliche
hintergrund und motiv interessiert wie
stets stimmig gespürt modell bis vor den
stehenden wagen und von der konstruktion
dass er mir vor allem interessiert und
wir biegen links ab
hätte ich gehöre zu einer gruppe
hier ist eine absperrung
aber wenn sie ihre hände etwas
ausstrecken kommen sie näher
[Musik]
das ist wahrscheinlich von fries ist
nicht erlaubt
schauen wir weiter
was wir sehen ist der rand des
parthenons und deshalb 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
und es sind immer noch teile der
skulpturen übrig nur die ganze
mittelfeld möglichst konkret was da ist
schon was man sagt aber nie dazu bis von
ntp tier ist nur geschäftlich abriss
kauzes braucht es gar nicht so einfach
sagen wie sehr schön gemacht
wir können uns den kleineren tempel
anschauen wenn sie möchten
hier ist es ein bisschen steinig wir
schauen jetzt in richtung
der stil ist es die spitzen der säulen
sind anders sie haben
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie man
die nennt korinthische verzierungen
glaube das ist gold was hätte man sich
nur wenige die vorgabe nicht wirklich so
kann ich der premiere von ihm auch einen
stamm gebäude haben die planspiele der
platz der gruppe was hat das ist recht
groß ich habe mal in folge stellt darum
musst du dabei offen für einen genau das
hat mir richtig
lief ja
also eine schmale stärker sondern ist
unbedingt nötig selbst schauen warum
macht hat jedenfalls ein echtes fest
ja also für die steine vor der mauther
griechenlands zeitweilig sichere ausflug
war
zudem stand rumford enzio das haben wir
als erstellen besteht aber ist es sicher
oder typische die orte
ich bin froh dass maxi oder abonniert
also ja
in riad
[Musik]
trotz tiefer ja
dagegen ohne irgendwo ihnen
unser dank die lage immer mehr opfer
ob es gerade jetzt nicht mit dem
schweizer mittel wähler verspielt
bankomat schluss dass mark selbständige
der sprachausgabe ihm leitet das menü
oder prozess von gail des rates muss er
sei bereit beziehen und jetzt das
offensichtlich nicht geheim und peter
motorrad und marcel schäfer
sie können den final geben
sie möchten berger ja fragt wieviel 200
punkt 60 c max i
bis kurz vor schluss so kritisch ist gut
so du nutzt facebook dass das hat extrem
53 euro nach einer frage und noch mehr
gespürt dass man spüre und dem einen
gott hat mir einfach nicht vorbei
also 260 franken
riechen sie die noten bestehen sorry ich
an afrika gehen sie diese straße runter
links und dann rechts
dort ist ein weiterer fussgängerstreifen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aber schmerz ist also haben wir nicht
entscheiden sie sogar dass auch kirchen
nimm dir da los
[Musik]
wieder hier
hallo hallo ich jetzt hin
für blade linien einfach auf wenn marco
cassetti johannes ohne dass dafür ist
aber noch wichtig das ist ja praktisch
zeigt der stadt der frage bleibt ob sie
aber vor ort das sollte facebook und
internet service couchsurfing oder sind
natürlich sehr froh wie das lied machen
wo ganz normal aber sehr bemüht sie haut
wichtig wo dir noch eine andere idee von
der stadt athen
wenn man aus dem zusammenhang mit der
geologie blaues t shirt an und in arosa
hat das oder so und das geldbuße nicht
möglich gewesen
das mühsam eine ganz ganz ganz
bestimmten ort treffen was der wirkliche
ecke ist oder ob trümmer wurden einfach
wo genau ich aus der groß platz vom
treffpunkt
[Musik]
dank dass leute da
wir haben
hallo paraskevi sie darf mit platz 6 der
leitlinie noch ich sehe euch wie geht's
euch gut du dir auch gut für die
verspätung
[Musik]
das ganze zentrum ist gesperrt ich habe
keine ahnung was ihr der große ist in
dieser seltsamen statt
[Gelächter]
doch alles okay das kurze eck ab meine
großmutter ist hier also in meiner
wohnung und ich musste vor allem bei ihr
bleiben
unterwegs
[Musik]
also war das schreiben authentisch führt
mit der behinderung jetzt lager dass es
zum beispiel wiener art für sich geht
also dass die finanzierungen stützt
räume außerhalb stube da ist ja weil ich
so dass forte aber griechenland ist
japan muss sparen da ist sicher nicht
erneut völlig mit behinderung ja dass
das ist das bild das bild war die kab
hatte das gesellschaftsrechtliche
herstellungs repariert die verschiedenen
gruppen spezialschule schickt orangen t
sie ist es recht fortschrittliches
verständnis und seine frau mutig dass es
ja nicht mit der finanziellen situation
von irland oder von einer kultur von der
gesellschaft sondern wie dicke
gesellschaft
der jona zu nehmen sport haut es auch
nicht nur sauber und das wo man dagegen
wieder körperlich krise ja klar das
berichten die news über griechenland
aber griechenland ist nicht nur die
krise
das ist sehr klischiert stellt euch vor
ich komme in die schweiz um reden über
geld schokolade käse oder kuren
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist nicht die realität
es gibt so viele andere dinge zu
diskutieren über diesen ort und zu
entdecken und das ist wirklich
klischiert s2 worüber die leute sprechen
spüren dass sie jetzt krise sorry wenn
ich das noch mal fragen
aber diese dinge noch spürt die richtig
aber er glaubt krise die ja ging noch da
naja ich bin kein ökonom in der familie
zum beispiel die gefühle sind sicher so
dass die leute angst haben
sie sind nicht sicher mit wie viel geld
sie pensioniert werden oder wie viele
steuern sie zahlen müssen
[Musik]
oder sie haben angst gefeiert zu werden
stell dir vor leute fragen sich nach
seiner sehbehinderung
so wird es doch sagen dass du immer noch
versucht zu machen was auch immer
möglich ist und das leben in vollen
zügen genießt
schutzbriefe es ist nicht das gleiche
ich versuche eine parallele zu ziehen
damit er es besser versteht
[Musik]
ein
das durchführen
also bietet an airbus das ist die krise
geht weiß jetzt auch dass gut die krise
gespürt was eben angst macht ist dass
das so eine ideale tour intelligent sie
das land fälle also im land geldbörse
verloren also das betrifft das ist neu
für mich und gleichzeitig talente und
die derzeit mit schaffe das da sich das
mir verblieb von einem griechenland
[Musik]
mehr
wir sind an der endstation hier ihr
könnt mir kommen die jungs merken
ich habe angst zu schwimmen weil ich
keinen schweren körper habe
die menschen würden eine wegrennen
nein sie sind jung sie sind schön wie
schön sie auch keine angst aber ich bin
alt alles hängt jetzt einen kleinen
schritt neben deinen freund es war sehr
schön euch kennenzulernen
[Musik]
für mich vor dem athen schon nächte
bleiben auch die freundlichkeit oder
nizza die mancher wo im koffer die
gemütlichkeit vor deiner stoff oder eine
straße mit einer kaffee mit einer straße
musiker helfen dass die stadt aber
zeichnung das glück servicekette warum
das ist nicht gedanken machen wie sie
zum beispiel halt nicht irgendetwas
falsch machen sondern dass sie auch mal
helfen
[Musik]
entdeckt nach berlin